what's going on everyone it's axelbeatz
here for anime uproar and we are
steadily approaching december when the
jiu jitsu kaizen movie will be released
and honestly i'm still on a high from
the amazing visuals from the demon
slayer movie so i'm pretty excited for
this one as well today though i'm going
to be covering jujutsu kaizen zero which
is the manga series that the movie will
be based on i'm going to try and focus
on the main events and major characters
this way when you go to see the movie
there's still plenty of fun things to
look forward to that you won't have
spoiled for you that said if you are
trying to go into the movie with a fresh
look with no information you've been
warned if you enjoy this video though
and want to see more jujutsu kaizen
content on this channel or you just
can't wait for the movie like me be sure
to hit that like button and if you're
new here or if you just haven't
subscribed yet be sure to click that
bell down below to subscribe to anime
uproar so you can be sure that you don't
miss any of our new videos finally you
can also follow anime upper on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar or you can
follow myself at excellionyt but with
all that out of the way let's get into
jiu jitsu kaizen zero jiu jitsu kaizen
zero is a prequel or prelude to the full
story of jiu jitsu kaizen and this story
begins with two children a young girl
named rika and a young boy named yuta as
many kids do these two do that cute
thing where they promise to get married
one day and rika even gives yuta an
engagement ring however this is very
short-lived as we jump forward in time
to see that she's been ran over by a car
and that her head has been crushed her
body starts to morph into a curse and
she starts to say yuta once we become
adults will get married it's a promise
and with that her cursed spirit bound
itself to utah from here yuta's life
becomes a living nightmare the curse
rika acts to protect him without his
control and starts to even hurt those
around him
as a result yuta starts to keep to
himself becoming shy and quiet however
this unfortunately leads to him being
bullied
we only really see one example of this
but it's pretty gruesome yuta begs for
the bully to stop for his own safety but
the bully just ignores him and as he
goes on to harass utah rika emerges and
crams the bully as well as three other
children all inside one locker and it
really does seem like she would have to
play a lot of tetris with their bodies
to make them fit this believe it or not
draws attention to yuta and leads us to
the first scene of jiu jitsu kaizen zero
where he is brought into a room with
gojo very similar to how yuji had been
in the main series
as gojo enters he finds a knife that is
bent and mangled and yuta explains that
he tried to end his own life but rika
just won't let him
he is terrified of hurting others and
committed himself to isolation since he
can't end his own life gojo asks if he's
going to be lonely by himself and
instead asks if he'd rather come and
learn how to control rika instead of
just throwing his life away and with
that yuta joins the jiu-jitsu school in
a very similar fashion to how yuji had
he's brought to meet his classmates who
end up being toge panda and maki and the
second that the door opens all three of
them pick up on rika and launch their
feet ready to attack luckily gojo is
able to calm them down though before
rika emerges to kill them something
which in true gojo fashion he forgot to
warn them of yuta again just like yuji
is set up with a partner to go on his
first mission again dealing with some
missing children from a school that
suspects curses are to blame he and maki
arrive to clear out the curses most of
whom are small fries which makes this a
great first mission for him
we also briefly go into curse grades
where we learn that yuta is one of only
four special grade sorcerers along with
gojo which i mean you saw rika that
checks out to me we don't really get too
much time to focus on this though as a
massive curse appears throwing both of
them into the air and swallowing them
inside the curse's stomach they find the
missing children and we see maki's leg
is wounded and festering with curse
energy she asked yuta why he joined the
school in the first place and he said
that he wanted to gain confidence and
feel like he's allowed to live and she
tells him that if he wants to gain
confidence that he needs to do things
that mean something for example
defeating curses and now is the time to
act he calls upon rika for the first
time intentionally and the monstrous
curse easily defeats the gigantic enemy
even gojo is thrown off by rika's power
the cursed girl smiles and asks yuta if
he loves her only to notice that he is
gone and carrying maki to gojo for help
along the way the human form of rika
minus the top half of her head appears
behind him to cheer him on yuta begins
to remember more of what happened and
starts to think that maybe rika wasn't
the one to curse him but instead it
might be the other way around and gojo
says it's unclear but love is the most
twisted curse of all so anything is
possible and here you to vows to release
rika from her curse meanwhile much like
the higher ups are against yuji it seems
they're also against utah as well and
again we see gojo taking a guardian role
vouching for yuta he says it's better to
let him live so they can learn from rika
as she's a very unique case in honesty
while gojo might be interested in this
to some degree he is more interested in
making sure that no one's youth is
wasted or taken from them regardless of
the situation as gojo leaves one of the
higher ups warn him that the execution
of yuta is only on hold and gojo
responds if it comes to that i will side
with yuta with one of the most
terrifying glances that he's ever given
yuta starts training with maki which is
probably one of the best teachers you
can have and gojo gives him a katana so
that he can learn to use rika's power
pouring small amounts of it into the
blade at a time to practice as he learns
to slowly undo the curse this leads into
a pretty fun set of training sessions
with maki and of course panda asking
yuta if he likes big or small boobs to
see if maki has a chance it's a really
light fun and wholesome section but it
isn't long before another mission pops
up and gojo sends toge to deal with it
asking yuta to join and watch so he can
learn that said he is given the warning
not to let rika out because if he does
everyone will likely die which is the
closest i've ever seen to gojo admitting
that someone else might be stronger than
him the expectation in general for this
mission was a lot of curses to be
present but for them to be fairly weak
most of them were pretty easy for toki
to take out all at once that is until a
much more powerful curse arrives toge
originally wants to take him on himself
but yuta steps up and wanted to help he
starts to approach the curse and rika is
in full horror rage mode he channels her
into his katana and we see him moving
around in a confident and fast paced way
which really shows off how much his
training is paying off even with that
though he just still isn't strong enough
yet despite that he does manage to
create an opening for toge and together
they are able to take this monster down
this extra strong curse wasn't just a
random occurrence though as the next
panel shows ghetto who seems to have
released it into this area intentionally
speaking of ghetto we get a look at his
perspective and his plans in particular
we have a few scenes with him
demonstrating how he views non-sorcerers
as monkeys who are either to supply him
with money or curse spirits and if they
can't get him either of those they might
as well die in fact his overall plan is
just to wage a war where they will
annihilate all non-sorcerers and he
isn't alone in this he has a whole group
that he calls his family who are in it
with him finally we also get a look at
how his abilities work with him having a
black ball that he can use to absorb or
release demons essentially like a cursed
pokemon master he's soon after this
arrives at the school to confront utah
asking him to join their cause
he ultimately wants to kill yuta to take
his costa rica unfortunately though he
made the mistake of insulting maki which
upsets yuta to the point of knocking
ghetto away he then explains that he
can't help anyone who would belittle his
friends
gojo then asks ghetto why he's even here
and ghetto explains that he's declaring
war explaining that on december 24th he
will march 1 000 kurd spirits onto
shinjuku to kill every non-sorcerer
finally the day of the war arrives and
while maki and utah are at the school
everyone else seems to have gone to
shinjuku the pair has a bit of time to
talk and maki explains that she is
considered a failure because she has no
cursed energy so her goal is to become a
powerful sorcerer go back home and see
their faces when she proves them wrong
which to yuta is an inspiration saying
that he wants to live as strongly as she
does which if it wasn't for the ending
of this manga would be enough to make me
start shipping these two together as she
gets very flustered for being accepted
we don't get to focus on this too much
though as ghetto arrives at the school
and places a curtain around it the whole
explanation for an attack on shinjuku
was just set up to get everyone else
away from utah and it worked gojo
realizes what is happening and he sends
toge and panda back to the school with
some warp ring that he made on the floor
hoping that they can help against ghetto
as he takes everyone else on here and
together maki panda and toge totally
take ghetto down and save the day by
which i mean that they get absolutely
rocked and ghetto wins with little to no
effort yuta arrives and finds his
friends laid out on the ground sending
him into an absolute rage and calling
rika to battle as both he and ghetto say
that they will kill each other the
battle kicks off and rika grabs maki
however it seems like yuta is able to
control her much better now as he calls
her off what's interesting is seeing
rika's reaction to this immediately
apologizing on repeat and begging you to
not to be mad at her as she starts
crying he calms her down and instead
sends her to fight ghetto as he starts
to heal maki once maki is safe he asks
rika to follow his movements and it's an
all-out battle ghetto has tons of curses
everywhere zarika summons a megaphone
with toge's curse ability imbued into it
and yuta calls out telling them all to
die from here they swap to a
hand-to-hand fight and it is wild
everything is incredibly fast-paced
until utah's sword breaks and before
ghetto can finish talking down to him
yuta lands a massive punch pushed into a
corner ghetto decides to pull out all of
the stops he summons an imaginary
vengeful spirit and then combines all of
his nearly forty five hundred other
curses
into one abomination utah two makes his
next move as he turns to rika and hugs
her he thanks her for protecting him and
asks her to lend her power one more time
promising to give his life to her after
this battle so that they can be together
forever he says he loves her they kiss
and rika basically evolves calling out
how much she loves him together they
fire off one final blast and wipe
ghetto's curses out entirely ghetto is
insanely injured at this point but he
manages to get away from the fight where
he is found by gojo ghetto laughed
saying that he essentially sent panda
and toge to their death however gojo
says that he just simply trusted ghetto
to not kill young sorcerers so he knew
that panda and the others would most
likely be safe however in general ghetto
is just too far gone and gojo is forced
to kill his ex-friend meanwhile yuta is
just waking up and rika's cursed form
begins to fade away leaving just the
young girl he once knew gojo arrives and
explains that he looked into yuta's
ancestry and he found out that they're
actually distant cousins which explains
why yuta's cursed energy is just so
strong and from here we learn what truly
happened when rika died it wasn't rika
who cursed yuta but instead the love
struck utah rejected her death and in an
attempt to save her he demands that she
not die thus creating a contract where
she would serve him as cursed rica
however now that the one who established
the curse had revoked the master and
servant status that was originally put
in place to keep her around
and now that rika clearly doesn't want
to punish him for doing so
they are both totally free yuta begins
breaking down as he realizes everything
was his fault he transformed her into a
monster
and he made her hurt people
however rika just hugs him and thanks
him for all of the extra time they had
together because the last few years even
given the circumstances were the best
that she's ever had because she could be
so close to him she says her final
goodbye and tells him to be well
only asking that he not come to the
other side too quickly and to enjoy his
life as her body fades away into balls
of light that float into the sky
and that
heartbreaking ending is where jiu jitsu
kaizen zero comes to an end i am so
excited for this movie there are a ton
of characters i didn't really get to go
into here who are super fun or super
dark that will be great on the big
screen but most of all i know that this
is going to bring me to absolute tears
when they get to the end of the movie
and turn me into a massive crying baby
some things that i really like in this
story are all the obvious parallels
between yuta and yuji
also i really like the chemistry between
maki and utah even if i kind of hope
they don't get together because of rika
that said i am very excited for a maki
and yuta reunion now that she has gone
through the whole setting extermination
thing this clearly isn't the way that
she meant to do things when they talked
in the classroom so i would love to see
yuta's reaction to that it should all be
pretty damn interesting but i would love
to hear what you guys think on the
subject as well as if you're excited for
the movie if you guys enjoyed this jiu
jitsu kaizen video and want to see more
please leave a like and if you're new to
anime upload remember to subscribe and
ring the bell of course you can also
follow anime uproar at anime uproar on
twitter or instagram or you can follow
myself at excellionyt i want to give a
big thank you to all of our patrons over
on patreon who allow videos like this to
be possible especially the patron of
legend the one who's acknowledged by
lord twigo himself alpha sigma as well
our the one tier patrons the ones who
stand above all clans in grata patahepha
al-jatal hinokami and water the toasted
chi the spike eight two two seven corey
mcgowan dylan isadore spidey life tinel
tungsten tarkus baked buddhist cody
hebert and monkey d quilly finally our
pro hero tier patrons gilgamesh the
red-haired raven annel cruz rathwind de
ora very gucci alicia ochter bonnie
parks joanne garcia ted noted fat boy
games and soulrise slice and dice if you
enjoy our work or maybe think we just
offer a little bit of extra enjoyment in
your day-to-day life please consider
going to patreon.com anime uproar and
supporting the channel for as little as
one dollar you will get your name
featured in future videos as well as
have access to our exclusive patron only
discord you can also join the youtube
channel by clicking that blue join
button next to the subscribe option but
whichever way you support us you will
get these same great benefits thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time stay excellent
[Music]
okay